veamos si podemos asignarle un nombre a
este sujeto que tenemos aquí verdad y
primero tenemos que buscar la cadena o
el ciclo más largo y yo creo que es
bastante obvio cuál es porque aquí
tenemos ciclos de longitud cuatro este
es un ciclo de tres átomos de carbono y
aquí tendríamos cadenas de a lo más tres
átomos de carbono verdad entonces
tendríamos que la estructura principal
es justo esta que estoy en marcando en
verde y que es un ciclo de uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho átomos de
carbono entonces esto significa que el
nombre digamos de nuestra estructura
principal sería ciclo octano verdad
ciclo octano porque es justamente un
anillo ok de de que es hoy está formado
de ocho átomos de carbono y la
terminación a no se refiere a que es una
calca no que es decir que hay puros
enlaces simples entonces ahora vamos a
tratar de ver cuáles son los grupos al
kilo que se ramifican de esta estructura
y aquí por ejemplo podemos ver cuatro
de carbono arreglados digamos en forma
cíclica y eso significa que este es un
ciclo útil verdad el prefijo wood es
para cuatro átomos de carbono y lo mismo
podemos decir de este que estoy
enmarcando de este lado verdad también
es un ciclo útil
ahora bien este de aquí este de aquí es
un anillo de tres átomos de carbono
entonces para cuando tenemos tres átomos
de carbono va el prefijo prop y como es
un anillo este sería un ciclo propio
ciclo propio vamos a ver qué ocurre con
los grupos que se ramifican aquí abajo
si se dan cuenta son exactamente el
mismo grupo solo están en distintos
lugares y estos están formados por
cuatro átomos de carbono cuando tenemos
cuatro átomos de carbono vamos a
utilizar el prefijo wood pero están
digamos en esta estructura de verdad en
esta forma de iu y cuando tenemos esta
forma de iu vamos a decir que el grupo
es un hizo útil verdad este es un piso
útil es más bien son grupos isobutilo
pero que en el nombre los vamos a
escribir como hizo útil
entonces ya que tenemos digamos
bien bien claro cuáles son los grupos al
kilo que se estan ramificando de nuestra
estructura principal ahora nos resta
enumerar cuál es el que más bien nos
falta determinar cuál es el primer
carbono que vamos a en el que vamos a
empezar nuestra enumeración y después
vamos a ver cuál es el orden en el que
tenemos que enumerar este es este ciclo
verdad y ya sabemos que el primer átomo
de carbono debe corresponder a dos
cuando haya uno o más bien al al grupo
al kilo que sea el primero en el orden
alfabético verdad entonces si nos
fijamos éstos tienen el inicio con ciclo
es decir con una c mientras que estos
grupos hizo útil pues empiezan con iu y
la se va antes que la i y algo que hay
que remarcar es que cuando estamos
fijándonos en el nombre el prefijo ciclo
y el prefijo eso sí hay que
considerarlos en el orden alfabético
pero si tenemos el inicio
el prefijo de 36 tener todos esos no se
consideran en el orden alfabético verdad
entonces ya que tenemos es o bien
distinguido podemos ver que la cev antes
que la i y pues la vez que es la
siguiente letra que tendríamos que
considerar la beba antes que la p verdad
entonces hay que elegir de entre estos
dos ciclos but y los de estos dos grupos
ciclo but y lo cual es el que va a ser
el primero y la forma de enumerar es la
siguiente necesitamos hacerlo de tal
suerte que aparezcan los grupos al kilo
de forma más rápida por ejemplo si
empezamos a enumerar aquí este tendría
que ser el segundo verdad para que sea
la forma más rápida de que aparezcan
entonces si seguimos esta enumeración
tendremos cuatro cinco seis y siete si
nos fijamos en la lista de los átomos de
carbono de este de este ciclo en donde
aparecen grupos al kilo en este caso
sería 1 2 4 6 y 7 4 6 y 7 ahora déjenme
déjenme borrar estos números de aquí y
vamos a ver qué pasaría si lo empezamos
en el grupo en el otro grupo ciclo
butilo
aunque qué pasaría si empezamos no aquí
sino empezamos acá entonces para que
aparezcan los grupos al kilo de forma
más rápida éste tendría que ser el
segundo luego tercero cuarto quinto
sexto y séptimo entonces vamos a ver
cómo es la lista de los grupos al kilo
que aparecen en esta en este en este
ciclo es verdad entonces tendríamos el
primero y el segundo tendríamos el
primero el segundo el cuarto y luego
aparece el quinto y en el séptimo verdad
quinto y séptimo entonces si nos fijamos
de estas dos listas ésta es en la que
aparecen de forma más rápida verdad
porque en el primero en el segundo y en
el cuarto coinciden pero este aparece en
el quinto mientras que en la primera
aparece hasta el sexto entonces esta es
la forma de enumerar ahí ya los tenemos
enumerados y ahora simplemente tenemos
que escribir el nombre de la forma que
ya sabemos verdad tenemos que asignarlos
de forma alfabética entonces el 1er
de ellos justamente será el del ciclo
útil y podemos ver que aparece en el 1 y
en el 4 entonces tendremos 14 de ciclo
útil y pongo el di
justamente porque son dos grupos ciclo
útil ahora cuál sería el que sigue sigue
el ciclo propio y verdad entonces el
ciclo propio aparece en el átomo 2
entonces tendremos 2 ciclo propio
y luego tenemos dos grupos isobutilo
verdad aparecen en el 5 y en el 7
entonces tengo 57 de isobutilo
y terminamos con el nombre de la
estructura principal que es el ciclo
octano ciclo tan entonces este es el
nombre completo de esta molécula 1.4 de
ciclo útil 2 ciclo propio y 57 liso útil
ciclo octano verdad y hemos terminado
hemos descubierto el nombre de esta
molécula y es bastante entretenido es
que es realmente cómo encontrar un
código secreto o algo así verdad 11 a lo
mejor no se esperaría que nos hemos
nombrar moléculas orgánicas de una forma
tan satisfactoria pero lo es